[Music]
he Daniel former NFL quarterback and uh
you'll love the Chase Daniel show on
YouTube he breaks down everything he
knows what he's talking about when it
comes to quarterbacks and he joins us on
the program all right Chase Lions what
they did on
Sunday how would you factor in
everything with the game the location
what you normally do what the ners were
doing like how do you come up with the
decision either you're with Dan Campbell
or against him yeah I mean look this is
what Dan Campbell has done the entire
year long and so I believe that what he
felt was right he was very excited about
it he was very confident about it you
saw these shots on the sideline they
kept going to him but I my push back
would be you got to understand that
there's moments in certain games the NFC
Championship Game on the road the first
fourth down okay they kicked it the
second fourth down he went for it they
didn't get it you had a chance to go up
three scores and when you have a chance
to go up 17 points you're up 14 on the
road in a hostile environment with Brock
py not playing well in the first half
and really this third quarter is when he
started heating up you have to take it
the three-score deficit for someone like
uh the other quarterback does something
with your mind you're like man okay I
can get two scores but when you hit that
17-point threshold in my opinion that's
tough to come back from the pressure
mounts on you you got to understand
where you're playing so look I think he
should have kicked both of them and I
know people are like well if they would
have made it you know you wouldn't be
saying that and they would be winning if
he kicks just one of them their tied
game they're going overtime if he kicks
both of them and this is saying make
them okay if he kicks both of them they
win the game and I get it back agley was
a 48 yard field goal he's 45% in his
career at 48 yards and above I
understand that but he must have really
liked the play call or whatever it was
but I look I I played with Dan as a
player in 2009 and he coached the tight
ends when I was in
2017 back in New Orleans for my second
uh flight there so I understand his
thinking he's very confident in what he
does and he almost wills it to happen
but it didn't happen for him and I'm
sure he's going to regret that for a
long time all right break down Brock pie
with the good and the bad with Brock pie
so far what when does he get why is he
bad and then why is he all of a sudden
really good well look the first half was
awful I think he threw for 45 yards or
something something insane interception
the interception was really bad and you
got to understand when you're when
you're backed up you can't just throw it
I know it got tipped but I think it was
going to get intercepted regardless and
I think the the game plan really changed
in the second half they started
spreading everyone out and empty and he
started just finding completions they
got Debo Samuel involved and I think
that this is the biggest thing that
separates Brock from say a Jimmy G or
other quarterbacks that that Kyle shanan
had in that system is his legs he ran
for 51 yards right four yards less than
what Lamar Jackson ran against the
Chiefs so that's an
underwhelming part of his game that that
people need to understand that this when
this happens like that it's huge when
things are covered downfield if you can
just go out of the pocket and move to
your right to your left up in the pocket
just buy that extra time it puts a lot
of stress on the defense and look I've
been saying this the whole time Dan on
my YouTube show on NFL Network National
TV like I don't understand the Brock py
slander at all and that's the biggest
issue I have with so-called experts that
don't even watch the film they watch a
couple highlights the dude has been
making throws in plays the entire year
that I've only seen a handful of
quarterbacks make in their entire career
I've been a part of I've seen that the
way he layers throws over top of
linebacker heads uh underneath the third
level and the safeties is something I
really haven't seen in a long time
breaking down film and yeah he struggled
I get it but he also you got to give
them the credit because they were down
17 they scored 27 points in the third
and fourth quarter combined to go on and
take the lead so I think this was a good
Learning lesson for Brock look he's been
a starter for two years was really half
the year last year and all the Year this
year and he's got into to back-to-back
NFC championship games he's got an NFC
Championship win under his belt and he's
going against the king and Patrick
Mahomes which I think is going to be a
pretty good game in my opinion well I'm
just trying to understand are we going
to see Brock pie the second half Brock
pie in the first half of the super does
he do they start that way to get him
into a comfort uh level well I I don't
think you can start that way against
Steve spagnol and these Chiefs because
these Chiefs are do doing on defense
right now it's special right spags is
bitching you from all different areas of
the field he understands he's playing
multiple Personnel groupings and that's
sort of what Kyle Shanahan does on
offense they like to get in these big
Personnel groups and a lot of teams
don't match them so they're able to run
the football I think the biggest thing
that the 49ers have to do in the biggest
stage of Brock P's like small career is
you got to run the football early and
often you got to get Brock into a rhythm
and if they can do that and Brock can
get the feeli of the game I don't think
it's going to start coming with him uh
until the third and fourth quarter
meeing like I don't think he's going to
start feeling it I mean he might start
fast but this is the longest leadup to
the biggest game you're ever going to
play in your entire life right and
there's so many other things forget
about the football side of things for a
second okay this when he woke up on
Monday yesterday he had to figure out
what family members are going what hotel
are they going to stay out where am I
going to fly my family from who in my
family's going to get to go I can only
buy 15 tickets okay I got to get the
tickets right I got to understand hey do
I need to prepare more in the first week
or should I just go about my business
not prepare at all should I go into
there are so many things other than
football that he has to worry about and
my advice to him being a part of it and
being a part of with Drew Brees is get
all the stuff that doesn't matter out of
the way in the first four and five days
and then spend the next 10 days just
focusing on football you got to have a
no man what does that mean you got to
have somebody in your click party the
bad guy because you don't want to deal
with it I would turn my phone off I
would just say hey if you need anything
go through my dad he can be he looks
like he could be a good no man to me or
his mom or his friend or his buddy or
somebody so he can just focus on the
main thing and that main thing is
winning a Super Bowl we're talking to
Chase Daniel former NFL quarterback and
host of The Chase Daniel show on YouTube
I'm wondering about the Chiefs what what
Baltimore was expecting and what
Baltimore saw because we kept waiting
for Lamar to be Lamar why wasn't he the
M you know the MVP
version well I mean that's the narrative
about him right he's two and four in the
playoffs he's only won two playoff games
he's going to end up having two MVPs and
that's great and all and even even Lamar
said hey look I'm getting old I need to
win a Super Bowl and that's the thing
about me like I I do think Lamar I
wouldn't say Laden egg but I don't think
he played up to his standard obviously
three turnovers on offense their whole
team had four personal foul penalties
but when you actually break it down and
you look at Lamar in the throws he was
off kelter off Rhythm the entire day and
that has to do with Steve spagnola's
defense I I think that what Steve
Spagnola did they confused him they got
into a lot of different personel
groupings six in fact Steve spola did
they were in nickel they were in Bas
they were in heavy they were in 64 they
were in 4-3 they were in so many
different things and it sort of confused
Lamar and you got to give credit to the
secondary as well for the Chiefs they
played excellent Jerry with a huge Punch
Out Of Z flowers and I just think the
championship experience of the chief's
overall team played a factor I I've I've
talked to a lot of people that oh
Championship experience doesn't matter
yes it does the Chiefs had no turnovers
they didn't have any personal foul
penalties they didn't uh shoot
themselves in the foot like Baltimore
did and then you look at the play
calling on Baltimore's side it didn't
help out Lamar they put everything on
Lamar that Todd mon in the OC for the
Baltimore Ravens he only ran the ball 16
times they were averaging coming into
the game running the ball 31 times Gus
Edwards got three carries his first
Carry went for 15 yards and he ended up
with 20 on three carries and the game
never got above 10 points so I just
didn't understand the game plan I think
Lamar didn't play well I think it was
like the perfect storm of hey look the
Chiefs went in there handled business
they had the championship experience and
then you also talk about Lamar and his
narrative about him right what I said
earlier they built this entire thing
around him and he is yet to break
through for a legit Legacy defining win
can you teach Patrick Mahomes to
somebody else another
quarterback oh man uh I think the
biggest thing about Patrick Mahomes that
I've noticed this year is he's sort of
taken a step back he's evolved and he
hasn't had to win a lot of games and I
think that's the biggest thing you're
seeing here especially into the playoffs
with Andy Reid and Matt naggie the OC uh
for the Chiefs they're calling a really
balanced game through three playoff
games the Chiefs have only thrown the
ball 11 more times than they've ran the
ball and I think you got to give credit
to momes I think you got to give credit
to that offensive staff and that's the
best thing I've seen about momes he's
not forcing things he's not taking sacks
he's really done a good job and he even
said it in the press conference when he
was praising Steve spagnol he said I've
had to take a step back and understand
how to play the game a little bit
different because we have a once in a
generation type defense and so they're
winning games because of the defense but
I do think when you look at the playoffs
in those three games they're starting to
cook and that's bad news for San Fran
defense which has gotten run over the
past two playoff games always great
stuff we appreciate your time Chase and
uh good luck with the YouTube channel
thanks for having me on guys that's
Chase Daniel uh the Chase Daniel show on
YouTube